[Musique]
ce mercredi 20 octobre a vu la
conférence de presse de lancement du
grand raid à la salle car vegan à
saint-pierre dans le départ sera donné
ce jeudi 21 octobre
propriétaire de 95 % de forêts publiques
le département investit chaque année
plus de 8 millions d'euros pour la
gestion des sentiers chanson dispensant
des sentiers des cours du grand raid
font partie de la forêt départementaux
de manière
donc le département intervient en terme
gestionnaire puisque c'est lui qui va
entretenir valoriser et puis permettre à
ce que chaque croix puisse emprunter
s'est senti vraiment pris conscience que
l' envie et là au niveau du département
de
préserver valoriser les espaces naturels
sensibles à la veille du départ les
trailer de la diagonale des fous se sont
vus remettre leurs dossards après la
crise sanitaire et l'annulation de la
course en 2020 la joie et l'excitation
se lit sur les visages et en fait c'est
le plaisir de courir d'aller dans la
montagne moines vider la tête d'être en
contact avec le nature des oiseaux riz a
été d'entendre les notes vous voyagez
quoi voilà pour ce voyage à tête on vide
la tête
avec beaucoup de joie déjà envie après
j'ai pas forcément de pression
le stress les habitants restent un ultra
on va passer de nombreuses heures sur le
sentier même le procès qui sont du vent
donc déjà vrai c'est avant tout le
plaisir des lecteurs au départ ce jeudi
21 octobre à 21h les 2870 trailer
inscrits prendront le départ de cette
course mythique déterminé à rallier
saint denis après 160 km et 9400 m de
dénivelé positif
[Musique]